all right so the King of Spades is
arguably the big bad of Alice in
Borderlands season 2 and he's by far the
face card who does the most damage to
those stuck in the game though Mira is
the one the players face last the king
definitely feels like the biggest threat
but he also Remains the biggest mystery
whereas the other kings and queens spend
time introducing themselves and talking
to the players the king keeps himself to
himself the only thing that we really
learn about him is the vision that we
see him having as a younger man that
appears on screen for a split second
because of this you might be wondering
what that's all about and who he is
luckily the manga fills it in and in
this video we're going to be breaking
down his backstory to give you a better
idea about who he is if you enjoy it
then please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day by the way huge
thank you for clicking this hope you had
a great Christmas now let's get into the
breakdown alright so the King of Spades
is actually a man known as ISO shirabi
he first debuted in chapter 32 of the
manga and he appeared similar how he did
in season 2 too however whereas in that
he just showed up and started shooting
people the manga played it slightly
differently the blimp appeared and the
characters started to investigate them
with one going to scare out the area and
see what they are two binoculars they
looked over the blimps and ended up
spotting the king's one after looking at
it they got a glimpse of a scope Flash
and before they could even move a sniper
bullet struck them introducing the king
in a big bad way from this point onwards
he started indiscriminately taking
people out which is sort of mirrored in
the show in the series he uses an
anti-tank rifle at the beginning which
is complete Overkill now unlike the
other face cards the King of Spades has
complete jurisdiction over Borderland
whereas they are stationary and
restricted to a certain area he has free
roam turned on and can shove anywhere on
the map at random now this is why he
appears in the city one minute and then
pops up in the forest the next during
the manga a lot of players run out there
because they believe that he couldn't
travel to that part of the map however
he shut up like what we see in the show
and burned a large part of it during his
attack and the King also has his own
strategies and ways of carrying things
out Beyond just showing up at places
there's actually a method to the madness
and sharabi normally Waits until people
are gathered in one area so you can get
the most amount of players in the
shortest amount of time whereas most
people believe there would be safety in
numbers he disproves that by killing
people in quick succession his entire
tactic is to ambush people and by the
time his blimp has drifted in he's
normally fully set up somewhere and
ready to take everyone out now though
he's a villain he actually views himself
as a hero Because he believes he has an
insight to life that many don't possess
sharabi believes that life is painful
and filled with misery and that by
killing people he's actually saving them
from the pain of it this was a mind
state that was something he developed
after his time as a mercenary which is
what we see in a flashback in the manga
shirabi was highly sought after and when
he was on holiday in Tokyo his old
friend Apache reached out to him with a
job sharabi suspicious of it and he
viewed it as being a mission that was
gonna just be a Slaughter he told Apache
not to do it and said that he'd be
killed if he went ahead with the job
Apache thanked him for being such a good
friend and sharabi basically said that
he's not really a friend and though
they're allies today if they got hired
for opposite jobs they might be on
opposite sides he said they were
business rivals but Apache clearly
didn't see it that way even though he
had a really bad feeling about it drabi
still accepted the job with his
quote-unquote friend and as predicted it
was a complete show the battle was a
Slaughter and they'd indeed been sent in
as sacrificial Lambs upon fleeing the
battlefield both were shot but sharabi
suffered but a flesh wound Apache on the
other hand was in critical condition and
though sharabi had said they weren't
friends he still did whatever he could
to pull his friend out they made it
quite far too but Apache said that he
was just slowing his friend down and
that he should leave him shurabi didn't
want to do this and he rested alongside
him with which is when they both agreed
to meet each other as friends of War on
another Battlefield after this Apache
asked him to kill him which sharabi
didn't really want to do however Apache
explained that he was suffering and that
the rest of his life would be a misery
he asked sharabi to kill him and said
that he would save him from the agony
that his life was gonna be this is where
we saw him in the vision and he killed
Apache at this point which is where he
also developed the Mind state that he
should ease people of the burden of
their lives now when the media struck
shrabi was closer to the center of the
blast and thus he ended before the main
players that we end up following in the
show as the show States time moves
differently in Borderland the entire
time arisu spent down there it was just
a minute in our world so if someone was
hit even just 10 seconds earlier then
they'd arrive down there months earlier
kyum and shirabi both arrived five
months before Ari suited and thus they
had time to play out an entire cycle
kyuma actually worked alongside shirabi
and Mira who all became friends she
bumped into him while he was burying a
body and it turned out that sharabi had
actually been going through Borderland
and burying those that had been killed
he didn't want to leave the corpses
behind for the Predators to eat and he
thought that death should have some
dignity to it Mira planted a seed with a
body and he promised to come water every
day so that it could grow the three
players met up every morning and after
making it to the final game they decided
to do it all together they won and then
they were given the choice to return to
the real world or remain in Borderland
now a lot of people have been like why
the [ __ ] would you want to stay it's
something that we've seen throughout the
series with several characters debating
why anyone would want to remain behind
in this hell a sharabi it was simple
though as we've discovered throughout
the video sharabi carried a certain
outlook on life and he viewed the
battlefield as being a burden due to his
skills he thought that he was one of the
only people that could shelter it and
decided to remain behind and kill those
that were bound to feel the suffering of
life so that's basically his backstory
and his outlook on life shirabi also was
of course a master when it came to
weapons and his blimp is completely
packed with them he gained supplies by
returning to it and whatever he needs is
sent down by Parachute which is where he
can pick it up in the end he tried one
final Ambush like what we see in the
series and this eventually led to his
undoing though he ended up killing a ton
of people he was eventually defeated by
the players teaming up when he would
strike a large group he he expected them
all to panic and flee and the player is
not doing this and working together is
what eventually brought him down the
battle in the manga plays out much like
what we see in the series with the
players throwing pretty much everything
that they have at him in order to
finally take him down it's completely
Relentless and the King doesn't let up
at all however they managed to break
through and beat him which is when he's
finally defeated in his dying brats we
see him apologize to Apache for what he
did he says that it was the only way he
could save him in the series we see a
flashback of the memory that made him
the way that he is and it's the perfect
way to say goodbye to this very striking
character and that's everything you need
to know about the King of Spades and
he's definitely one of my favorite
people in the show completely Relentless
I absolutely loved when they went
through his backstory in the manga and I
kind of wish that we got it in the
series too no we didn't I think that the
series does enough to tease at it and
hopefully this video has piqued your
interest so that you go and read it
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the character so make sure you
comment below and let me know we are in
competition right now and we're giving
away tone of the dead and Black Adam to
three subscribers on the 15th of January
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the show we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if that's you
if you want someone else to watch then
we've got a video on the screen right
now that goes through what the Joker
card actually means for the ending it's
a big Cliffhanger and I know a lot of
people are confused about it but the
manga actually answers is exactly what's
going on and yeah if you if you're still
scratching your head over it then
definitely go check that out after this
by the way thanks for sticking through
the video I hope you enjoy the rest of
the holidays and yet you take care
yourself and have a Merry Christmas much
love hope to see on the next one peace
[Music]